what's going on guys you know we love
talking about the box-office
blockbusters the tentpole movies the
behemoth but today we're going to
venture into some deeper darker
territory to talk about two movies that
may not quite be on your radar in a
segment we like to call the best movies
that you've never seen volume 2 and we
got a couple of cool fellas to talk
about it with first you know em you'll
love them from around here at screen
junkies
he's also the host of does it hold up
welcome back to the show Spencer Gilbert
thanks for having me man of course and
oh man I want to thank this guy for
coming across the hall you know Matt the
movie fight champion and the host of
Dan's labyrinth every Monday dan Merle
happy to be here how today let's talk
about the thought processes behind this
episode we're not saying that these are
movies no one's ever heard of yeah we're
not going full hipster like this movie
was only released in Belgium on tidal
we're going like half hipster like
you've heard of this be proud of
yourself there you go so we each brought
in a handful of films that meant
something to us that we want to talk
about let's jump in and start with
Spencer tell us a movie that made your
list
my first pick is a film called four
lions you guys like comedy right yeah
yeah do you guys like Islamic terrorism
no the amazing thing about this movie
and why I don't think it got heralded is
it combined the two this is a comedy
about four guys in Britain that sneak
off to join al-qaeda
it's a mockumentary it doesn't sound
funny it's hilarious and I argue that
this does more to combat the appeal of
terrorism than any Jack Bauer good guys
versus the bad guys movie ever will
because to me it's so much more
beautiful and poetic and effective to
paint these guys as bumbling idiots than
is to paint them as the big evil force
have to get us
these guys are hopeless they're losers
and they act like it
the way you're describing it the
producers does that a little bit making
fun of the Third Reich in World War 2
springtime for Hitler in Germany really
pokes fun at something that otherwise
might be really hard to laugh at Dan
speaking of Nazis my first movie is
probably the most well known out of my
picks just because this is how great I
think this movie is called The Rocketeer
came out in 1991 stars Billy Campbell's
this guy named cliff Secord who finds an
experimental rocket pack and becomes
this superhero goes around on a rocket
pack called The Rocketeer Billy
Campbell's great in it Alan Arkin is
that it he's great you're very young
Jennifer Connelly is in it when she is
great and really Timothy Dalton plays a
guy called Neville Sinclair who's a
Hollywood star slash Nazi spy and a
great must literally mustache twirling
villian performance the stakes are high
is a great fight on a Zeppelin of course
they were made of hydrogen back then so
you can see where that's going it's set
in Hollywood so it's like that kind of
glitzy 1930s Hollywood glamour okay and
it's that kind of original thing that
people love with superhero movies that
we don't get as much anymore this is a
very much revered film from my childhood
and it's something that I think people
would still enjoy yeah superhero movie
with a heart that will you know scratch
that superhero at you yeah for sure yeah
while I land with jetpacks - music okay
I'll throw one out there this is 2005's
Rob Zombie horror action or The Devil's
Rejects it's super violent it creates a
world of its own and it's got gore and
it's got gunplay and it's got big cars
and it's got you know chicks in it it's
real like it is a non-stop aggro thrill
ride and super bloody how does that not
as a poster oh yeah you're giving a box
close oh thank you but yeah check out
the Devil's Rejects redder kids go to
Mike Trout I haven't seen this but I've
heard people either saying like oh my
god I love this movie or oh my god those
are the worst movies of everything which
is great yeah it's great for movies that
that are polarizing a challenge
audiences yeah absolutely uh Spencer
talk to us okay my second film is French
wait there nothing else right Lily is a
French action thriller so the best way I
can describe this it's called une profit
or a profit it's a combination of the
Godfather Shawshank and crank if you can
get over the subtitles you're in for a
good time it's about a teenager who goes
into prison
hence the Shawshank most of it takes
place in jail caught between two warring
prison gangs both run by different mobs
and the crank factor comes in is he's
one of the only ones with outside
privileges so he gets to go outside a
few days of the year and he has to run
these missions for the mob on this time
limit while also attending to his life a
little outside of prison I want to see
that movie after the way you've
described it's so awesome but you just
the subtitles are tough to get over I
know but if you can do that and pay
attention and not be on your phone and
actually read what's happening sure I
watch movies because I hate Rudy I get
that but if you can get over that hump
it's great for sure dan talked to us
last time I was on screen junkies and
every time I watch screen junkies I
talked about shattered glass one of my
favorite movies this is a movie from the
same guy who wrote directed shattered
glass his name is Billy Ray and it's
called breach and it's the story of a
real-life FBI double agent essentially
for years he was feeding information to
the Russians the Soviet Union and it's a
really great political thriller which I
loved and kind of by you like I love
that tension of just like we have to get
the palms at the time it was a Palm
Pilot so get the data you know I guess
very much of its time because you had
that you know we have you have to
distract them while we partner in this
car yeah exactly like like you have that
kind of tension but more than anything
also this was a great performance by
Chris Cooper and if you like political
thrillers if you like spy drama zits it
is a great one of those and it's a
real-life story there's so much tension
in this movie and I really like it I'll
throw it out there it's called naked
it's a little bit of a depressing movie
but the central performance by David
Thewlis who's an actor you'll recognize
he's a professor lupin whoa Harry Potter
yes absolutely
this performance playing this kind of
aimless
vagabond wandering the streets of London
in the middle of the night if you like
just philosophy and boozing
sounds like my freshman year of college
yeah yeah boozing it's the kind of movie
you watch in college and you're like
this movie so deep it's a blue dog thing
oh well it's a Boondock Saints with
without flamboyant low and Dafoe
that was a great moment Oh Benny G throw
us another guy's let me take you back to
1986 a more innocent time the time where
developers were always looking to get
one over on a small town and the only
way to fight back was with a BMX bike
making of course of the movie rad just
the word read and that really tells you
all you need to know I mean this movie
is so pure 80s and has such good
eighties music to it all that it is one
of the best examples of the form and
it's one of the best unintentional
comedies of all time if you think you've
laughed before at intentional comedy
wait until you see him and his prom date
slow dance each of them on BMX bikes and
the long time circling each other my
hand increasing and the wheelies popping
until they can't help themselves anymore
this movie is so read it is definitely
rata Dan mine is a comedies from 1984
people think of these as team I'm
talking about the Zucker brothers Jim
Abraham's the guys that did airplane
they think of airplane in 1980 they
think of Naked Gun in 1988 what they
don't think of is one in the middle is
called top secret 1984 Val Kilmer stars
as Nick rivers who's basically Elvis and
he goes undercover in World War two to
infiltrate the Nazis and it is airplanes
one of the greatest comedies ever made
and make a gun is up there too I would
put top secret if not on the same level
just a peg below both of those movies as
far as gags as far as just genuine
laughs they have a whole scene in
Reverse and realize it's in Reverse
until halfway through it I have like
little visual pictures in my mind like
picking up a giant phone the gags are
just as stupid as the ones an airplane
today
oh that's too but just this funny yes it
all sounds like some bad movie
for my next tool I want to talk about
let's get in like the way way back
machine and talk about a movie from 1946
what my dad turned me on to a film
called the best years of our lives and
it is one of the most thoughtful films
about veterans returning home from war
and my dad a veteran himself really
loved and appreciated this movie Harold
Russell was a veteran who actually lost
his hands and so his character has hooks
for hands and just dealt with very real
issues this film just is a stark
beautiful look at what it's really like
for people it definitely had a time yeah
it's like you're saying for so many
years the only thing that you saw in the
militant and the Hollywood in the
military was like here's our boys and go
coming home to my gal and that was that
was military service we came home a hero
and and I don't think until the 70s
really did they again delve into the
reality of coming home and what a
veteran and they go better in this life
in the post-vietnam area then you
started have films like The Deer Hunter
and other coming hauling hood yeah
exactly exactly absolutely worth
checking out okay so my next pick is a
film called repo man and it's not it's
from the 80s it's not that weird mm
organ harvesting film repo men okay this
is a move by director Alex Cox it
combines sci-fi punk rock and Emilio
Estevez um that's a pretty sweet combo
right uh he's like this a wayward punk
rocker who needs a job he becomes a repo
man and he gets really into like
repossessing people think but they
repossess the wrong car it's one with
like an alien nuclear device in the back
of it it's surreal it's funny it's a
commentary on consumerism and all the
other punk rock things at the time this
movie is so it reminds me so much of
Robocop it just doesn't have a robot cop
in it it has Emilio Estevez I think it's
too late for us to get romantically
involved
Iran so if you're into any of those
things you definitely go check it out
good stuff Spencer it's a good movie and
my last one is a movie from 2000 that is
actually I
I am afraid and acts
danger of being forgotten this movie
that was written and directed by Rob
Lurie it's called The Contender Joan
Allen stars she plays basically the vice
president has died the president played
by Jeff Bridges nominates her to be the
vice president and she has to go through
her basically it's not confirmation
hearing necessarily but it's an advise
and consent hearing that's led by Gary
Oldman who plays the real son of a [ __ ]
movie and basically they try to destroy
her they try to politically assassinate
her in order to have somebody else take
that spot Syrian community I'm asking
you to do what's in the best interest of
the party and this president so I'm
sorry I can't do it this is an
oscar-nominated movie it was highly
critically acclaimed when it came out
and it is in danger of completely
disappearing because I had to find it
recently and I found that it is not on
blu-ray it is out of print on DVD you
can't get it on iTunes it's not
streaming anywhere it's not streaming on
Netflix it's not streaming on Amazon
this movie is essentially unless you're
doing what I had to do which is go to
the library and check it out on DVD Wow
you essentially cannot find this movie
anywhere right now and that's sad
because I think that as as we've gone
through so many iterations of home media
in the last two decades one I feel like
there is a handful of movies like this
that are going to get lost this is
absolutely one of them the contender the
contender check it out check it out
literally check it out from your local
library until they find that a way to
make it available is this the first time
screen junkies has ever sent people to
the library I think it might we go to
the library and check out the contender
that's a great suggestion absolutely
thanks then I want to thank you guys
especially for adding to my already long
list of movies that I do need to watch
and I want to thank you so have you seen
any of the movies that we talked about
or are there any of your own hidden gems
that you feel like people need to know
more about let us know about these
movies in the comments below we want to
know I want to thank my good pal Spencer
Gilbert dan Merle thank you fellows for
coming across the hall and thanks for
the great conversation thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye
hey guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show
honest trailers movie fights and more